hallo so läuft das Team Store
richtig lecker
[Musik]
hallo zusammen heute gibt es wieder ein
nee sorry drei drei Tiramisu Rezepte für
euch und zwar im Mini Format dass man
sich so zu zweit gönnen kann ich habe
mir gedacht ach wieso nutze ich nicht
diese Verpackung von Ferrero Rocher es
gab ja letztens erst die Rocher Torte
aber verlinke ich euch gerne am Ende des
Videos gibt ja immer diese coolen
Packungen und da habe ich gedacht warum
eigentlich immer wegschmeißen dann
benutzt ihr schon so für Krimskrams
manchmal und heute habe ich mir gedacht
einfach auswaschen und Tiramisu drin
zubereiten und das ganze in drei
Varianten und alle drei Varianten haben
aber die gleiche Grundmasse dafür
brauchen wir hier nur Mascarpone Sahne
Vanilleextrakt und Puderzucker und dann
geht es direkt an den Zubereitung
[Musik]
so die Creme geht ganz einfach indem ihr
alle Zutaten in die Schüssel gibt und
dann erst langsam verrührt dann
verbindet sich alles zu einer homogenen
Masse und dann könnt ihr immer schneller
werden mit der Geschwindigkeit und das
ganze wird schön fest ich habe jetzt
auch kein Sahnefest mit drin ich wollte
das heute nicht weil ich wollte gerne
die Festigkeit durch Kühlzeit erreicht
man hat das noch mal so eine andere
Konsistenz so und die Masse teilen wir
jetzt auf und geben ein Drittel hier mit
rein und ein Drittel hier mit rein und
dann verrate ich euch auf welche
Varianten das heute gibt
[Musik]
so die bleibt jetzt klassisch denn da
kommen Preise werden gleich in die
Zwischenschichten Variante 2 möchte ich
gerne mit Karamell da könnt ihr eine
fertige Karamellsoße nehmen oder ihr
nehmt einfach meine trilette Soße die
kommt dann auch noch in die
Zwischenschichten und die Variante 3
passend zum Winter spekulos Karamell
also diese Spekulatius Karamellcreme bei
der muss sich allerdings sagen dass es
von der gesamten cream family die die
ein bisschen also die am feststen ist
von allen und daher würde ich die jetzt
gerne für ungefähr zehn Sekunden in der
Mikrowelle erwärmen einfach Deckel ab
und nur so ein bisschen geschmeidiger
machen damit man sie unter die sehr sehr
zarte Creme rühren kann aufs Brot wäre
das jetzt kein Problem aber in der Creme
noch mal ganz kurz erwärmen
[Musik]
so jetzt habe ich mir die erste Creme
und zwar die Vanillecreme in meinen
Spritzbeutel gefüllt mit Lochtülle dann
könnt ihr einfach flexibler bleiben ob
wir am Ende diese typischen Tiramisu
Tupfer macht und dann wird das Ganze
geschichtet die Amarettini nur für zwei
Sekunden in Espresso tunken nicht zu
lang es wird dann mit der Kühlzeit schön
weich und anschließend schön Schichten
[Musik]
nach der preiselbeerschicht gerne noch
mal eine dünne Schicht Creme dazwischen
geben anschließend noch mal die Amaretto
Schicht und mit Creme abschließen so
wenn ihr mögt könnt ihr jetzt noch Kakao
oben drüber geben das ist es so ganz
typisch aber nicht direkt weil sonst
kommt dazu viel Kakao durch euer Sieb
macht gerne den Trick dass ihr einfach
Linsen oder irgendwelche Hülsenfrüchte
in das Sieb rein gibt dann sucht sich
der Kakao nämlich seinen Weg und ihr
habt das so richtig schön verteilt und
nicht alles auf einmal
[Musik]
so unser Tiramisu Nummer zwei da kommt
jetzt die trilece Creme mit dazu und die
habe ich schon in meinen Spritzbeutel
gefüllt in denselben und jetzt kommt der
ganz klassisch den Löffelbiskuit zum
Einsatz ich kann mir nicht vorstellen
dass man den Sau snackt weil man da Bock
drauf hat sondern wirklich immer nur
wenn man irgendwas süßes macht und jetzt
auch wieder nur zwei Sekunden eintunken
abtropfen lassen und dann in die Form
geben und Schichten zusammen mit der
Creme und gerne auch eine dünne Schicht
trilece-soße mit einbinden oder auch
zwei
[Musik]
so ich glaube das wird man Favorit denn
jetzt nehmen wir uns diese spekulus
Kekse und tunken die auch wieder in
Espresso auch wieder nur zwei Sekunden
dann Schichten und hier versuche ich so
viele Schichten wie möglich einfach zu
kreieren Creme Keks Creme Keks immer so
weiter und schließe dann einfach mit
Kekskrümeln ab
[Musik]
so jetzt ist auch unser spekulus
Tiramisu fertig alle drei Varianten
kommen jetzt noch mal in den Kühlschrank
ich persönlich finde je länger desto
besser also wenn ihr jetzt keine Geduld
habt dann reichen eigentlich 30 bis 60
Minuten aber ihr müsst euch vorstellen
die Konsistenz verändert sich von Stunde
zu Stunde und wenn ihr zum Beispiel vier
oder sechs Stunden Zeit habt oder sogar
am Vortag macht dann habt ihr so eine
richtig schöne halbfeste aber dennoch
cremige Masse daher werde ich
wahrscheinlich erst morgen probieren ich
gedulde mich ja auch wenn es mir schwer
fällt also sehen wir uns dann morgen zum
Test wieder
[Musik]
[Applaus]
tasty testi mit Menschen die uns zusehen
draußen vom Fenster aber Hamza wir
dürfen uns nicht schämen müssen kleiner
durchgehen
hallo so läuft das Team im Store ich
habe nur schon mal so setisfying
Aufnahmen für tiktok gemacht wir haben
auf tiktok noch nicht vorgestellt
Verpackung
Upcycling
boah Leute ich habe jetzt die Version
mit den Preiselbeeren unnormal lecker
und normal ich habe amarettin hier drin
das Match so gut oh das ist endlich
im Café bei uns abbieten das mega lecker
bei jedem Test anbieten das müssen wir
einen Kaffee anbieten
Moment kommen Sie mal zu meiner Rechten
ich kann ihn hier was empfehlen und zwar
haben wir hier einmalig unsere spekulus
Karamell cream wollte ich nur mal zeigen
das was sie haben wir jetzt hier
Marzipan eigentlich
weiß ich nicht aber ich hatte auch so
Marzipan Feeling aber eigentlich nicht
es sind Amarettini mit Preiselbeeren
keine Ahnung schmeckt auf jeden Fall
krass nach Marzipan obwohl kein Marzipan
ich sag mal nix das ist schon gefährlich
nee ich habe teelöffelbiskuits hier habe
ich spekulus Kekse und hier Amarettini
und das ist schon gefährlich eins sollte
für zwei Personen reichen aber Kaffee
ist überall mit drin
immer drin jetzt schmeckt es ne Karamell
das ist auch richtig lecker Spekulatius
Karamell ist auch richtig richtig geil
ich finde alle geil zehn von zehn zehn
von zehn zehn von zehn ich kann egal
Leute unbedingt nachmachen mega lecker
unbedingt
kaufst und dann sagst okay weißt du was
ich mache jetzt was damit mega cool ist
man kann sogar den Deckel drauf und das
ganze verschließen und später wieder
essen es gibt auch immer einen Deckel
dazu
es ist ein Rocher
platzierungsvideo Produktvideo davon
kommen die von meiner Torte und das war
auch keine Produktplatzierung ja also
frei ein Stück also echt lecker
nachmachen viel Spaß beim Nachmachen und
bis zum nächsten Mal tschüss
[Musik]
[Applaus]